demonstrators gathered in front of
leipzig st. nicholas church Michele
shona was one of those who took to the
streets in 1989 to protest against
dictatorship and for freedom
he's off let's appease aside this square
and the one in front of the Opera House
would chalk full of people in the end
70,000 marched around the ring road
lingual yatin it was an overwhelming
feeling just crazy from week to week the
demonstrations grew larger until they
sparked a revolution that couldn't be
stopped on november nine 1989 the East
German regime opened the borders it's
what it was very moving it lost sign
something's happening yes maybe we've
won a bit of freedom how often is
required in communist East Germany shuna
operated a television and electronics
repair shop with a staff of seven I've
had given our skills we weren't
disadvantaged much because they needed
us but I didn't like the political
situation after the Berlin Wall fell
shona had to make his business fit to
compete in the free market economy
instead of repairing old electronic
devices he started selling new ones
today his son has taken over the running
of the family business espanha shayan
for Thomas it wasn't easy at the time
but as a father I'm proud that my son
has followed in my footsteps and
expanded the business and he understands
all this newfangled technology then this
protease annoyance ah what a political
and a technological revolution Michele
shona has lived through both
Oh